Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video I'm explaining the shocking ending
of The Invisible Man, and the thrilling twists
and clues that led to that big moment.
Plus, I'll reveal how the finale connects
to the new Invisible Woman film.
Spoilers, of course, for the movie, so take
care if you haven't seen it yet.
The film's first jaw-dropping surprise happens
when Cecilia is at dinner with her sister,
Emily and out of nowhere the Invisible Man
slashes Emily's throat and pins the murder
on Cee by placing the knife in her hand.
Leading up to this, Adrian has been slowly
making Cecilia look and feel crazy, first
faking his own death, then stalking and terrorising
her at her friend's house.
One of the first big clues foreshadowing Emily's
murder comes when Cecilia is alone in the
house with The Invisible Man, and she decides
to call Adrian's cell phone which buzzes from
the attic above.
Cee climbs up and after finding the phone
together with a large kitchen knife, a text
message pops up with the single word "SURPRISE".
She can't figure out why there's a knife there,
but the sign that it's a future murder weapon
is how it's already bagged like it's a piece
of evidence.
When she's later locked up and drugged in
a mental hospital for the crime and what everyone
thinks are her delusional ravings, an invisible
Adrian whispers "surprise", tormenting her
that he had this moment planned all along.
The word, and idea of, "surprise" pays off
in an even bigger way in the movie's final
twist.
When Cee goes to have dinner with Adrian,
he still thinks he's in control and tells
her
"I know you better than anyone else in the
world;
that shouldn't come as a... surprise."
The way Adrian pauses, smiles, and then emphasises
the word "surprise" is his way of letting
her know that it was indeed him who killed
her sister and has been torturing her, not
just his brother.
His constant denials at the dinner table prior
to this are yet another example of how he
gaslights her.
And so, sick of his continued abuse, Cecilia
excuses herself to the bathroom, then off-camera
sneaks into the bedroom closet where she recovers
the invisibility suit she hid there earlier.
Invisible now, she walks back to the dinner
table and, aware of the security cameras,
makes him slit his own throat, mirroring the
way he killed her sister.
As he dies, she whispers the word "Surprise!"
showing that she's turned his own tricks back
on him.
By the way, notice how Cecilia decided they
eat steak, rather than the sushi or pasta
she was also offered, for dinner, so that
Adrian would be holding the knife she needed
to kill him.
And a clue that Cee would decide to wear the
invisibility suit against Adrian was hinted
at in the hospital on a poster titled "You
don't have to face yourself alone".
The poster features two silhouetted figures,
and while it's obviously aimed at people with
mental health issues, maybe bipolar for example,
it also plays on the idea of Cee using an
alternate invisible persona to deal with Adrian
as well as the fact that we soon discover
that a second man donned the invisible suit.
Indeed, doubles and mirrors are a recurring
theme in the movie, with Cecilia seeing a
reflection of herself in the bathroom mirror
just before she puts the invisible suit on
to kill Adrian.
And part of the set-up for Cecilia hiding
the second invisibility suit in the bedroom
closet comes in the scene where she goes for
a job interview and the interviewer says
"we both know the value of closet space".
The comment refers to him starting his company
in a supply closet as well as Cecilia's time
in Paris when she stayed in an apartment as
small as a broom closet.
Which points forward to the film's finale,
as well as back to the start of the movie
where Cee hid a go-bag in her closet to help
her escape Adrian.
As we discover in another twist, Adrian's
brother Tom was also his accomplice, helping
him fake his own death, and even once wearing
the suit.
Tom claimed he'd been controlled by Adrian
all his life.
And while that may be true, he still lied
to Cecilia, feeding her false information,
essentially gaslighting her as well.
"Only thing more brilliant than inventing
something that makes you invisible is not
inventing it, and making you think he did."
When Cee tells Tom he's just a 'jellyfish
version of his brother', she means he lacks
a spine, but the fact that jellyfish are known
for their translucent or transparent look
means it's also an intriguing nod to the fact
that Tom will later wear the invisible suit.
Tom was always quite shady from the start
knowing things he shouldn't, such as where
Cee was living.
Remember she received the letter about Adrian's
will at James's house, probably because when
Emily saw the news about his death, she ignored
Cee's instructions not to go there and Adrian
was tracking or watching her, just as Cee
predicted.
Tom also knew Cee had set up a bank account
for Sydney's college fund, again something
that should be private.
Most likely is that while Adrian was stalking
Cecilia and breaking in to her laptop, he
was keeping tabs on her and relaying the info
back to his brother.
As the saying goes, the greatest trick the
devil ever pulled was convincing the world
he didn't exist, an idea that perfectly fits
the character of the Invisible Man.
Even at the end of the movie, Adrian pretends
he was never the Invisible Man and that it
was his brother Tom who was responsible for
everything that happened.
Adrian flips the truth so far that he even
claims he's the victim and that Tom was controlling
him.
The movie's writer-director Leigh Whannell
has said that Adrian's emotional intelligence
and charm is a classic trait of narcissists
and sociopaths who he describes as "scientists
of the human condition [who] can break someone
down very quickly, assess their needs and
desires, and play to that."
Which is why Adrian is good at reading people.
For example, when they were still together,
he figured out without her even saying a word,
that she wanted to leave him.
And his reaction was that of a sociopath:
"Wherever you go, I'll be standing right behind
you.
I know you better than anyone else in the
world."
When Cecilia was wearing a wire at the end
and trying to get him to confess, you could
sense he probably knew what she was doing,
and on top of wanting to gaslight her as usual,
that was another reason he refused to admit
anything openly.
Likewise his comment that 'you're the only
person in the world who gets to see my hand
shake' was a tactic to let her know that only
she knows the truth about him and no one else
would believe her.
He also knew she was taking birth control
pills in secret so switched them out behind
her back, essentially drugging her so she'd
get pregnant, quite likely with Diazepam given
the very high level of it in her blood.
As Cecilia unwittingly continues to take the
drugs, Adrian breaks into her email, sending
a threatening, incriminating message from
her to her sister, which later provides the
motive for Emily's murder.
Adrian is constantly isolating Cee from the
few people already in her life as well as
any new people she comes into contact with.
He also sabotages her job interview that could
make her financially independent of his money
by emptying her portfolio.
And he later puts those architect plans that
he took in the attic, together with the kitchen
knife, taunting her about what he can do to
her.
He also sees himself as an amazing god-like
figure, the master of everyone and everything
around him.
When they were a couple, he was such a control
freak that he decided everything Cecilia did,
wore and said.
Even his dog Zeus wears a shock collar with
tech of Adrian's own design.
And let's talk about the name he chose for
that dog:
the ancient Greek deity Zeus is the king of
all the other gods and men, which again highlights
how Adrian imagines himself as the supreme
master and god of all.
And it's no coincidence that the location
of Adrian's house is Celestial Drive.
As a genius inventor, Adrian uses his invisibility
technology to psychologically and physically
terrorise Cecilia and those around her, to
make her appear unhinged and, ultimately,
drive her back to him.
When Cee asks The Invisible Man why he cares
about her, when with his wealth and power
he could have almost anyone, the answer that
Tom later gives her is that Adrian needs her
because she doesn't need him, and that nobody's
ever left him before.
Whannell has said that when he was writing
his first draft of the movie, he felt that
the themes "of gaslighting, domestic abuse
and not being believed or feeling like there's
an unseen threat" would perfectly fit a modern
version of the classic invisible man villain.
And Whannell went on to say that "the horror
genre lends itself to depicting the worst
of society's problems because it can illustrate
our collective fears.
Cecilia's character is an example of what
it's like for a woman to be driven to feel
'crazy' in the wake of abuse when no one around
you believes what you're saying."
Ultimately, as Cee couldn't make Adrian admit
his guilt, the legal options for getting justice
weren't available, so he would have continued
to terrorise her as the Invisible Man if she
didn't stay with him.
Which is why Whannell says that with the ending,
he decided "to give [Cecilia] some catharsis,
[as he] wanted [her] to feel free."
And so, as Cee walks out of Adrian's house,
free at last, we can see from her open bag
that she's still got her invisibility suit,
meaning she could easily be in a sequel or
possibly in Universal's The Invisible Woman
movie which is already in development with
Elizabeth Banks directing and starring as
the title character.
I wonder if the film will feature Banks donning
the suit and using it to violently deal with
people who've evaded justice such as abusers.
After all, according to The Hollywood Reporter,
the tone of the new film is "Thelma & Louise
meets American Psycho".
Although Universal have abandoned their Dark
Universe which was going to connect their
catalogue of classic monsters, it seems there's
potential for some sort of crossover, even
a very small one, if the studio did decide
it wants to make it happen.
If they did choose to connect the two movies,
then Cecilia could, for example, supply Banks's
Invisible Woman with the tech for the suit
or they could even team up.
Either way, as Cecilia shows in The Invisible
Man, stalking is a very real danger in real
life and online.
As well as covering up your laptop webcam
like Cecilia did to stop potential hackers
spying on her, you can also stop anyone, including
your own internet service provider, from tracking
you online with a virtual private network.
A VPN helps protect your privacy by encrypting
your internet connection and preventing your
ISP, government agencies or malicious hackers
from reading your emails, private messages
or knowing which websites you're visiting.
Which is the perfect intro for this video's
sponsor, NordVPN who offers one of the world's
best virtual private networks.
Here at Flicks And The City, we've tested
several VPNs and Nord is one of the best and
fastest.
It has over 5,000 servers to choose from in
over 60 countries, and when connected to Nord
we were still able to get blisteringly fast
download speeds.
Unlike many free VPNs, Nord has a no-log policy
meaning it doesn't record or retain details
of your online activity when you're connected
to its service.
And if you're a video junkie, NordVPN can
help you bypass geo-restrictions or censorship
on content not available to view in your country.
Just pick a server in another location and
browse the internet as if you were there.
NordVPN even works with Netflix.
Plus you can connect up to six devices at
the same time, including your laptop and phone,
so you can keep your mobile devices safe whenever
you're travelling and using public wifi.
For a limited time, NordVPN are offering all
our viewers up to 70% off new subscriptions
and a bonus subscription absolutely free.
Just visit NordVPN.com/FLICKS or tap the link
in the video description to access the offer.
That's NordVPN.com/FLICKS for a huge 70% discount
and an additional subscription period for
free.
So, what did you think of The Invisible Man,
the twists and the ending?
Leave your thoughts in the comments below.
If you enjoyed this, then a thumbs-up and
a share are hugely appreciated.
Tap left to watch my next horror movie video.
Or tap right for another video you're sure
to like.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!